hello and welcome to today's webinar my
name is Edward Pryor and I am a director
of product management here at Thermo
Fisher Scientific and I'll be your host
for today
at the recent Eminem conference in
Portland Oregon Therma Fisher announced
an exciting collaboration with
structural biotechnology to offer smart
epu with embedded crowd spark live
as you'll hear today smart epu with
embedded cryospark live enables
cryoelectron microscopy users of all
experience levels to acquire high
quality data while reducing the time it
takes to obtain 3D protein structural
information from days to hours
in today's webinar you'll hear from two
presenters Julio Ortiz senior product
marketing manager for cry OEM software
here at Thermo Fisher Scientific and Ali
punjani CEO at structural biotechnology
with that I'll turn it over to Julio to
begin our presentation
thank you very much Edward for the
introduction and thank you all of you
for your participation in this webinar I
hope you can find it useful because it's
about saving time make a better use of
your microscope and at the end become
more productive is about a medical
useful life software that we launched
recently in the last microscopy and
microanalysis meeting in Portland it is
a solution for integrated real-time data
analysis for high quality 3D protein
structures
I want to start calling the mission of
our company term official scientific
which is to enable our customers to make
the world healthier cleaner and savior
and it is very satisfying for us to see
publication of this kind an Evidence of
the direct impact that our products have
on medical research in this case Chen
Teng and Sen present us the
three-dimensional structure of different
complexes between the somato 13 receptor
and different G proteins
and they found something very
interesting with The Binding of some
compounds to the iron expanding pocket
of the receptor here at the top
they can
um
realize that there is a change in the
specificity of the receptor
for different G proteins and in
consequence different signaling pathways
to tell you the truth I I choose this
paper because I worked many many years
ago in transducing the G protein of the
visual system and this for me
um
fascinating what is happening nowadays
and this work was facilitated by the use
of our products a bit of what mark IV
for redification or cryotherm that I
don't cry use equipped with a ficon4 for
software acquisition they use Ebu in a
previous version 2.12 and the author for
data processing use a combined combined
techniques available in different
packages one of the increases Park which
is State Advance
software for for image analysis from our
collaborators estuda biotechnology
overall this story facilitated the
design of drugs with Selective G protein
signaling to improve the robotic
efficacy
and independently of the application we
celebrate or with the success of the
cryogen community because we know that
behind every of these structures there
is plenty of work
it's a word that starts with example
creation followed by biochemistry
optimization to enable cryogen the step
of vitrification is the relative
straightforward but with a very variable
rate of success because it depends of
sampled properties so you need to go
back and forth in an iterative way
between biochemistry optimization
vitrification and some data collection
at the microscope that we call the
screening until you are sure that your
protein is embedded in a very thin layer
of eyes and very well distributed in a
space
when you have achieved that you can
proceed with that acquisition the data
processing and the model building
Pipelines
as you see the workflow is complex in
the last two decades we have a focus on
this step of a screening and data
acquisition with our program epu we have
achieved a very good level of automation
but of course there is always a space
for improvements so we want to increase
this Automation and our vision is to as
facilitate the training of new users
make experimental setup a
straightforward reduce the operator time
expand at the microscope and ultimately
what we would like is a fully automated
attack position process
and for that we need help and we are
very glad that we receive help from our
collaborators technology
which have plenty of experience in
advance data processing and I have a
product also that is uh
operating exactly in this interface
between screening.acquisition and data
processing which is cryospark live
we decided to collaborate and our first
proposal forward is vision is the
integration of Crisis bug life into a
smart epu software we would like to
further automated at acquisition process
to allow a rapid
sample assessment and determining
further optimization is necessary
reduce the time to 3D and structural
information from days to hours and
facilitated on a stream data processing
for the rest of the presentation I have
the following outline I will present you
an introduction of a smart dpu
Ali will give an overview about Crazy
Life we answer the question what is
embedded crisis by life
we present a statement from Alexei rack
franzanovi who has opportunity to test
the software before we go to closing
remarks and questions
so good what is a smart TPU a smart TPU
software platform for that acquisition
and screening that aims higher degree of
Automation and easy of use it has three
functional blocks
the first one is about that acquisition
with the program's EPO 3 and EPO
multigrid over customers are used to
these programs
the second block is about image
evaluation with our Solutions epu
quality monitor
or embed equations by life and now you
know where to locate the new component
of smart TPU
and we have a third
um block that is about decision
algorithms that we call Smart plugins
they take information
from the images that have been evaluated
to modify the data acquisition
parameters on the Fly
um there is a fourth component of smart
TPU that is called Athena is over
software for data management and visual
reporting is shared with other
application and I love the communication
between the components of a smart TPU
and present the results to the users
in a web interface that you can access
everywhere
I will review very quickly the data
acquisition block EPO 3 and EPO
multigrid have a user interface
organized in tabs the first one is the
home page with Optical and Camera
presets thoughts for a fast start in
data collection
you don't need any more to introduce all
these parameters manually if you have
used these presets but you still have
access to them in the preparation tab
then you can create atlases for audio
grids in your auto loader these are load
magnification maps of your grids and Ebu
provides you already uh the initial
classification of your squares
then you have Auto functions with all
the routines that the program will need
for automatic data acquisition and you
have the final tab called also epu in
which you can go through the public
pipeline of creation of the session
first you need to curate the selection
of your squares you need to select holes
partially that is happening
automatically
you can Define templates of where to
acquire images on your holes
and once once you have set this session
for one grid
if you have epu multi-read then you can
apply the same preparation to other
grids in a queue system and then let it
run in an autonomous manner for hours or
days
then the programmers start to collect a
high resolution images
we can continue with the image
evaluation block and our program
EPO quality monitor or eqm
equal ampere executes motion correction
and CTF estimation and calculate a CTF
confident range which is a good metric
of image quality this enable the users
to immediately identify problematic
images and act to fix or escape the data
acquisition
allows users to filter and export only
quality data facilitated the
post-processing and it is embedded in
Athena portal for easy access anywhere
the peculiarity of having a PO quality
monitor inside a smart TPU is that the
data can fit a smart logins for
automated adjustment of data collection
parameters
with that I will turn the presentation
over to alipunjani
CEO from technology
for an introduction to Crazy spark life
please Ali
great thanks a lot Julio
so I'm going to take a few minutes and
give an overview of what christberg live
is what it does what its capabilities
are
Harrisburg live is a real-time Software
System that's designed to enable
processing of cryo-em data right at the
microscope and specifically to help
optimize data collection of single
particle data sets
the main purpose of Christ work live is
to complete the feedback loop that you
see here where a user can understand
their sample while it's still in the
microscope and then make data collection
decisions on the Fly
crestmark live can keep up with data
collection from typical cryo em
microscopes even at the fastest rates
and it helps to capture the value of
those microscopes and other criorium
equipment that has been acquired by
providing a seamless workflow that goes
through an entire end-to-end single
particle processing chain that starts
with pre-processing of the raw data
that's motion correction CTF estimation
particle picking and then streaming 2D
classification that leads to insights
right away about what is actually in
your sample followed by avanishio
reconstruction and high resolution 3D
refinement that let you get insight into
Diagnostics and other tools that can
help make those decisions at the
microscope
I'll go into some detail into all of
those phases of processing but overall
the purpose of Christ work live is to
simplify the process of getting to a
high resolution structure quickly from
cryo-em data
there are several use cases that I just
want to highlight that kreisberg live
really enables the first and most
important is to get rapid visual
feedback of your sample right in the
microscope that means you can get
insight into issues like preferred
orientation tell if your sample actually
even has a likelihood of reaching high
resolution by observing the statistics
of your data and those are all computed
in real time and together all that
feedback means that it's possible in
just a few hours to start making go and
no-go decisions about your data
collection maybe you have a bad grid
maybe you have a sample that needs to go
back to sample preparation all those
issues can be identified early on and
you can decide to stop collecting early
or collect further on the samples that
do turn out to be good
you can also find out what you need to
change about an ongoing data collection
that includes things like tilting the
stage changing your defocus settings Etc
the Insight that you get from christberg
live can also help to give information
all the way back up the chain in your
cryogen workflow back to sample
preparation where maybe you need to
change your vitrification or
purification strategy and now you can
know that right at this microscope
rather than waiting days after
collection is finished to find out that
you actually have to go back a step
all these insights together mean that
you can really enable this goal that
we've had for a number of years that's
now actually possible which is that you
can start with a sample start data
collection and within just a few hours
get enough insight to make decisions on
the Fly and then within a few more hours
hopefully less than a day even walk away
with a high resolution structure once
you've got that that can be your
starting point for further Advanced
processing in more advanced tools like
cryspark itself
I'm just going to go through a few of
the actual things that kreisberg live
does there are three main phases of
computation that happen in real time the
first phase is pre-processing meaning
motion correction CTF estimation
particle picking and particle extraction
that all happen on the fly as new data
comes in these tools are all automated
and all reprocessed data as you change
parameters or change inputs going into
the system
they also come with built-in interactive
tools right in the cryospark lab
interface that let you for example set
up automatic exposure curation so that
you can separate good and bad images
based on the attributes that are
computed from those early pre-processing
stages
it also lets you how it also helps you
to set up particle picking and iterate
that so that you can visually see what
your particles look like whether they're
being well picked well centered and so
on once all that is set up your data
collection can continue unattended and
results like streaming 2D classification
can be processed in real time
streaming 2D classification is the next
stage of processing in crosswork live
and it performs real-time classification
that lets you see an updating view every
few minutes of what's actually in your
sample
these 2D classes are computed in a way
where we don't have to go back through
the entire data set to update results
instead every few minutes as new
particles come in we can see what the 2D
classes are looking like and get really
quick really fast a sense of what's
happening in the sample as we move
around the grid and so on
once these 2D classes are computed and
you've selected which ones you think are
good the particles that fall into those
classes are automatically sent over to
the next stage of real-time processing
which is streaming three reconstruction
and refinement
Harrisburg live includes an integrated
AB initial reconstruction module that
can first produce an initial model if
you don't already have one it then takes
that initial model and refines it again
in real time updating every few minutes
as data comes in to high resolution
the high resolution refinement that you
get provides a lot of very important
Diagnostics that you can't get without
going to the 3D stage for example the
resolution estimate which updates again
every few minutes you can also look at
the 3D density map to look for issues
like streaking and other problems that
may occur due to sample orientation
issues and the orientation distribution
other Diagnostics that really paint a
picture of what's in the sample together
all these tools help to complete the
workflow and complete that Loop so that
a user can make decisions on the Fly
with that I'll head it back to Julio to
tell us more about embedded craftspark
live
thanks Ali and now that we have an
overview of both programs a smart TPU
and credit spot live let's talk about
the integrated solution a smart Apu with
embedded creative spark life
embedded credits for life is in
overblock for image evaluation and
enrich the capabilities that we had
previously with eqm with additional
tools for image analysis
embedded crisis per life is a version of
a structural biotechnology crisis part
life designed to seamlessly integrate
into terms of scientific smart TPU
software
we promote it as a Twinkie solution
because it's pre-installed and optimized
for maximum performance with thermofisha
microscopes
you don't have to worry about Hardware
or I.T issues
um because the program is updated by
digital service and the training is
provided by our application specialists
embeddy craze for Life enables users to
immediately identify key sample
characteristic and adjust acquisition
strategies to obtain maximal resource
results in the shortest possible time
is integrated into an extreme line
workflow with automated setup
configuration several parameters that in
the not embedded crash bar life version
uh were introduced manually
that have to do with the microscope now
are automatically
retrieved from from the instrument
and
um you have the Adina portal to image
the for visualizing the image transfer
and
access all the results of the workflow
something to record is that uh
embedicated sparklife forwards the smart
plugins for automatic adjustment of data
collection parameters as it was also
done by eqm
Now eqm versus embedded graders for Life
what is the difference I hope that the
difference is clear so you have with the
qm motion correlation and CTF estimation
for uh real-time image quality
information
with embedded craze for Life
Additionally you have particle peaking
to the classification and 3D
reconstruction refinement
for Life provides real-time image and
Sample quality information
giving users the powers to refine
Imaging and processing parameters
to succeed in the structure
determination
both
eqm and embedded credits per Life can
provide input for smart plugins
and what are those plugins that we have
been talking about at the moment we have
three smart plugins enabling feedback
loops for example if you monitor the the
focus value of your images you can
detect all ears from the desired Focus
range and the plugin will adjust the
focus of the microscope
so that the following images will remain
between the focus range that you
specified at the beginning of the
session
we have similar plugins for monitoring
the stage waiting time
and uh
first pro preventing
excessive of the sample and we have a
small grid Escape that considers the
metric of CTF confident range and
indicator of image quality and if
several images are recorded with a low
confident range
then the plugin Escape that grid
these are basic plugins we plan to add
new ones and then I am very optimistic
about the chances that embeddy craziest
bug life offers
to take the decision base on Sample
attributes
at this time I want to mention also that
we have a first application of
artificial intelligence in a smart TPU
and that is used during the setting of
the session it is called it is called a
smart selector
we have trained a neural and neural
network to identify
those holes that are suitable for high
resolution acquisition
and exclude all those
um holes that are contaminated or empty
they filter enhances that data quality
operates very quickly and is easy to use
this kind of Technology
um is what we expect to apply in Synergy
with embedded creators for life
for for their automation of the workflow
and this is a short video that we
prepare to give you an idea of how those
embeddy gray spark Life Works a very
greatest part of life is started from an
existing workflow Associated to an epu
session in Athena when you have selected
both you can install previous part live
with a couple of clicks the setup is
easier in the embedded version because
you only must set parameters not related
to the microscopal camera but with the
sample the particle size and extraction
box size you apply the parameters and
start the session
the inset at the lower right corner
display the corresponding smart dpu user
interface which is showing a data
acquisition session in progress
with the stage moving to selected places
on the grid and recording images
it takes around 30 seconds for
individual movies being loaded and
motion corrected
and this is a real time here in the clip
the individual exposures and their CTF
are displayed and you can easily browse
them and select filters based on image
quality
and automated particle picking is
started by default
this low picker method needs commonly
some manual interventions to adjust
parameters to the particular sample and
the images condition been used
it is useful for an initial extraction
of particles for 2D averages then can be
used later
as templates
for more specific picking
when enough data has been acquired you
can create a 3D app initial model for a
novel structure of your title Target
after a few hours of data collation and
for the refinements you can get a first
3D
high resolution model of your protein or
complex in this case apofheritine at
2.18 angstroms with 48 000 images around
4 hours from that acquisition start
I want to become more quantitative and
give you an impression of the time
needed for the many steps in the
workflow this is an example of execution
of a data collection
monitored by a embeddedical standard
life
here we use hypopharitin as Benchmark
protein sample on a glaciers with falcon
4.
due to the high symmetry of apoplectin
we know that about 90 minutes of the
calculation are enough to achieve a map
of high resolution
if you start simultaneously in very
close by life with a smart TPU data
collection
you can start the alignment and
classification of particles about 30
minutes after starting
and it will finish
almost right after the data calculation
has been stopped
this is possible in this system because
the data collation throughput is about
450 images per hour using office
while the throughput of embedic radius
per Life in pre-processing and extreme
2D
is about 580
image process by hour in 2D
um
for for other
systems and other kind of proteins the
times will change but I wanted to
mention
uh this capability of embedicated spark
life to
um
to cope with this
throughput in the data collection
later you can also start the trigger the
three-dimensional analysis
after one hour of data collection start
with about 65
000 particles
and this analysis of this number of
particles a will take about one hour and
it's a good decision point for a
perfectin to decide if you would like to
continue the processing until I have
processed all the data and achieve the
the 2.13
answer resolution
that happens more or less
3.5 hour after collection is stopped
um but as I said Authority in a special
case with the high symmetry
in
other examples
um them for more General Uses the
databulation will extend probably for
many hours or even days
um but it's still the outcome from
embeddy equations by life is a it's
meaningful and particularly a particular
useful in in these cases because you
will start to have
um
2D classes
during the the first hours of data
collection and even I really mentioned a
structure maybe a low resolution uh
in this fear of First hours that you can
easily decide if it's worth to continue
with the data collection or if you need
to interrupt it or modified some
parameters uh in the data acquisition
process
but let's continue
with a testimonial from Alexa crack
um head of the bio structural video
physics from synovic to summarize the
benefits of a smart TPU with embedded
queries for life
hello my name is Alex Iraq I'm heading
by a structure and biophysics department
at integrated drug Discovery France and
coordinating structure biology globally
in our company
our mission is to support and streamline
our drug Discovery projects by
rationalizing them that makes the
projects easier to execute and both time
and cost effect
since a couple of years we are using cry
em structure determination of protein
targets and protein complexes and
appreciate the cry em resolution
revolution technology advancement
especially from the moment when the
internalized crime back in 2020. the
technology is great and it is widely
applicable than x-ray crystallography it
really significantly reduces time for
Gene to structure process for the new
Targets in our operation however the
data collection and data processing time
for cryium structure termination if
reduced can be further impact in drug
Discovery so we are extremely happy to
have access now to the new smart epu
software as it enhances efficiency to
use Korea with a new software we can
optimize and do quicker images
evaluation and Analysis so that we do
not waste our time collecting not
meaningful data
further Automation in Ebu multi-grid is
also reducing time in setting up the
data collection and the embedded in the
smart epu cryo spark live allows to
pre-purchase the data and reduce
baldness of it which is important
especially when transferring and storing
the data on the cloud so the access to
the new smart epu will positively
contribute to our throughput and the
pace with which we are structurally
informing drug Discovery in sanofi which
means we can deliver faster the drugs to
the patients
thanks Alexa for your testimonial we
appreciate it
for my closing remarks I want to
highlight that a smart TPU with embedded
graduates for life is available in all
thermosientific cryotherms platforms the
tundra technicians and Aquarius
beside the benefits of the use of
microscope time more efficiently and the
connectivity to post-processing
workflows for me what is more exciting
about having a very graceful life are
the possibilities that the program opens
for the future
those of you who have worked at the
microscope know that most decisions we
take daily
are based on what we see
on the pictures we judge sample
attributes
now that the microscope are no longer
only taking images but can see the
sample
we can transfer the expertise of
microscopies to a Smart TPU
powered by AI Solutions
combining classical approaches with
trained neurodal networks we can achieve
a fully autonomous data acquisition
experience at the microscope
this might take time but we are feeling
firmly committed to that goal and we do
support
we can progress faster
I hope that you'll get enthusiastic
about it and adopt power software
very soon
I invite you to follow us in social
media and visit our web pages our
companies have additional information
about
empiricals about life
and before we answer some questions I
would like to thank you for your
attention and also thanks over R D team
I recently had the chance to participate
in a meeting with many developers and I
was very pleased to to see how are they
organized it's a very professional team
now we can answer some questions
all right thank you Julio thank you
ollie for
a very exciting presentation on embedded
cryospark live uh there have been a
number of questions that have come
through from the audience uh and so
we're going to try to get to as many of
these as possible in uh in the remainder
of the time so uh we'll start off with
Once uh Julio maybe this one to you uh
when will smart epu and eqm and embed
across spark live uh become available
and they are already available
we set the the files to download but of
course as I mentioned in the video
um our product is supported by our
Digital Services so once you get the
appropriate license they they can
install the software
great thanks Julio uh just moving along
uh Ali here's a question for you uh
can users export make sure I asked this
correctly yeah can users export the
output files generated by embedded
cryospark live and continue processing
that data on uh cryospark or other
post-processing software for example
absolutely that's a great question so
the short answer is yes absolutely
embedded cry spark live output data is
completely compatible for example with
the full standard price book that you
may have used before the outputs are
also available in sort of standard
formats that can be converted and
imported into other software for your
use
just to dive into the the downstream
interplay a little bit when you create a
new data processing session in embedded
Crossmark live embedded Crossmark live
will also create a cryspark project
folder and all of its output data will
be stored in there so as soon as that
that embedded chrysberg live processing
session is complete you can take that
project directory and import it into a
standard price Park instance that may be
installed on your own hardware and
continue doing Advanced processing just
as if you had done all the processing in
your own crossbar instance to begin with
so it's quite a seamless Connection in
that way
great thanks Ollie uh the next question
I think I can actually answer uh there's
been a few questions about uh Hardware
specifics uh so uh let's see here one
asking uh what server Hardware comes
with the package to support uh Crossmark
live processing uh and then another
question about uh where does crossbark
live Run is it on a designated server or
the or the camera server so uh basically
yeah the the answer to these two
questions is the same so we as part of
uh of the embedded craftspark live
offering we provide all of the hardware
necessary to run uh embedded craftspark
live uh and this runs on the on the DMP
server which is connected to uh
connected to the microscope
hopefully that answers uh both of those
questions and I think there's a few more
coming in now uh about
um
about Hardware where I think that same
answer
applies
um
here's maybe a question for for Julio
related to the first one I asked uh so
uh let's see I have epu 2 uh can I
upgrade to epu 3.0
oh yes the upgrade from EPO 2 to review
3.0 or X is a normal standard book rate
and it's included in the license that
most of the user have with the po2 so
it's a question just to upgrade the
software and it can be easily done uh to
get all the functionalities of a smart
epu you need to appropriate licenses
with a smart TPU uh blue cqm or a smart
TPU with MLA craze part life
foreign
here's a question on on cryospark live
so uh for for users again I'm trying to
combine a few questions into one for
users that already have or are already
using cryospark live
um can they connect that to Smart epu or
do they need something uh additional
another great question currently
chrysberg live does not connect to
Athena or smart epu embedded Chrysler
live is a solution that contains
alongside the algorithms that are in
cryspark live and the interactive tools
and everything else contains the
integration code that allows it to
connect it to Smart EPO and Athena so
that is one of the primary aspects of
embedded Car spark Labs that makes it
different
great thanks Ollie
um let's see
Julio I think this is a question you can
answer so uh what movie format does or
what what formats of movies does embed
across spark Live support
um and what are the output formats uh
for motion corrected images
Falcon 3 and 4 the formats that uh
embedicated about life users are MRC or
E ER and uh for the K2 or K3 it can be
um also Thief
compress format okay the output always
of the the average motion corrected
pictures are MRC yeah
great
thank you Julio a few more questions are
coming in about Hardware specifically so
maybe I didn't answer the the first time
correctly so when I when I said that you
know from Betty Crossmark live all the
hardware uh is is provided uh maybe I
could be a little bit more specific
about what specifically that is that
includes the
uh that includes the gpus uh the extra
memory and
um and SSD drive that uh those pieces of
Hardware required to to run embedded
Crossmark live and again that exists on
the on the DMV server
all right uh let's see just scrolling
through here trying to combine a few of
the questions that um
that have been asked here
um Ollie another question came in
um
similar to to the previous one uh but
maybe a little bit more clarification of
how does embedded crossbark live
interact with uh with cryospark
sure definitely I can answer that one so
um this is somewhat similar to what I
mentioned before about transferring of
files and importing of projects the way
that embedded chrysberg live and a
separate Chrysler instance interact is
that embedded crispark live creates
intermediate and final output data in a
format that's directly compatible with
craftspark you can also use those files
in other programs their standard MRC
files for particles MRC files for motion
corrected micrographs and chrysberg
output files that are readable by other
tools for metadata and things like that
but the the native outputs come out in a
format that is directly compatible with
cryospark so in particular as I
mentioned in medical christberg live
we'll create a Chrysler project
directory for every data collection
session that you run and that project
directory can be imported into your own
chrysberg instance at the same time or
at a later time for seamless further
processing of the data Advanced
processing and all the tools that you're
used to in price Park itself
great thanks Ollie
uh
question about eqm uh Julio maybe this
one to you uh can users have
yeah can users have both eqm and
embedded Car spark live on running on
the same instrument
well actually they are alternatives they
are exclusive because uh they uh the way
the software uh handle the information
provided by by the software
are unique so you have one uh or the
other image Evolution program
um embeddy previous pack live has all
the functionalities like eqm so um there
is maybe no reason to have
the two Alternatives running in the
semi-truth
great thanks Julio uh I'll take a stab
at answering this next question I think
it's uh pretty good so for uh the AI
that you you described Julio around
smart selector uh somebody had asked can
we change the setting and teach AI to
our needs and that's that's a great
suggestion right now the the neural
network that is used for smart selector
is a pre-trained neural network
however it is in our roadmap to to have
a little bit more robustness around uh
that algorithm and and uh have a
self-training algorithm based on the
samples that that are coming through
your your workflow so
um
as of right now uh uh right now it's a
pre-trained network but
um
uh but there's plans to make that a
little bit more robust
let's see
just going through a few of these have
been answered already in different forms
um
foreign
here's a good question for for you ollie
uh how or has
um
embedded crowdsparkle I've been modified
at all does it does it include different
or new functions with respect to
Standalone or yeah Standalone Car spark
live
great sure that's also a great question
so in terms of the core functionality
algorithms that are used for processing
the data itself and the actual outputs
that are created embedded Crossbrook
live in crestmark live are currently
exactly the same so they do the same
motion correction CTF estimation
particle picking 2D classification
refinements Etc the primary differences
are that embedded cryospark live has a
bi-directional interface with Athena and
epu it's also been optimized to work on
the specific Hardware that's going to be
shipped with it and specifically on two
gpus only
and it's also built in a way that
ensures that it can securely and in an
authenticated way access the Athena apis
and the all the instrumentation that
Thermo Fisher has for managing data that
comes out of the microscope the user
interface has also been changed just a
slight bit on the configuration tab for
those are familiar with chrysberg live
some of the options and inputs are no
longer necessary in embedded craftspark
live since those inputs come directly
from Athena and smartyp so there are
less inputs to provide before you can
start a session but otherwise the
interfaces for curating your data
looking at particle picks looking at the
micrographs those are all the same
great thanks ali uh another question
about availability uh maybe to you Julio
um is embedded crossbark live available
only on new instruments or new tools or
can it be installed on existing tools in
the field
in our new platforms but of course you
can make retrofits it can be installed
in an existing
um existing instruments
um everything depends of your
configuration so it's difficult to
answer the question because there are
many systems outside but of course if
you want to use a very creative
parallelog or in qm if you need Athena
Athena needs to run in a server as you
mentioned at EMP to server so for a
pre-existing instrument our
recommendation is to talk with our
account managers and with your icon
managers and they can provide a tailor
solution because we need to know which
is exactly the configuration that you
have in terms of hardware and so
software in software you probably need
also some
upgrades like the temp server and and
the Athena version
great thanks Julio
um maybe just one more
clarification on a previous answer uh
there's a question asking why do we need
to duplicate uh motion correction in CTF
you know one from Quality Water and one
from embedded cryospark live uh I think
this Julio uh for for you I think this
ties into the previous answer but maybe
uh just a little bit more clarity around
um around that about you know the
differences between eqm and embedded
cross-bark live and the fact that you
know it's either one or the other and
not both
yeah exactly so uh something that has in
common both programs is that they can
perform motion correction and CTA
estimation so if you have
only
a smart TPU with eqm you can do motion
correction CTF
if you have a smart TPU associated with
embedded radius per life then you have
also additionally
um 2D and 3D image processing okay but
uh what is common is motion correction
as CTF
I hope that answered the question
yeah I think that provided a little bit
uh a little bit more clarity there Julio
thank you
um let's see uh we're getting kind of
towards the bottom of all the questions
here so maybe just one or two more
uh questions let's see uh one actually
I'll take another stab at uh answering
this one about epu multi-grid I just
scroll by it yes someone asked is is epu
multi-grid included by default in smart
epu and uh and the answer to that is
that Apu multi-grid is is uh is separate
from Smart epu it's a it's an option uh
to be to be added to uh to Smart epu but
more information about that can be uh
yeah your account managers will have
more information about about that
uh let's see
I think we're almost at the bottom here
on questions
um again another question about the GPU
requirements for embedded crossbark live
uh how many gpus it's again this is
included with uh with the package and
it's uh as I mentioned before two gpus
are included to be installed on um
on the DMP server
uh
let's see I think all of the other
questions are sort of duplicates on the
other ones so
with that I might uh bring this q a
session to uh to a close uh Julio Ali
any uh closing remarks if any
um
we normally address the questions
afterwards uh also individually we can
send uh messages answer
um something that we couldn't cover
Maybe
great
well with that I just wanted to maybe
conclude this webinar by by thanking
everyone for their attendance and and I
hope that you all found uh this
presentation by Julio Ali interesting
and exciting on embedded craftspark live
and and please if there are any
additional questions that come up uh
please follow up with your account
manager or us directly so thank you and
I hope everyone uh has a great rest of
their uh afternoon or evening depending
on where you are in the world
thank you all